the Joe Rogan experience now did you run
into any issues where you really didn't
have any vegetables other than the the
vegetables in the stomach's of the
animals you ate your just eating meat
did you run any health issues just
living off a meat I've eaten a very high
protein high fat diet for long periods
of time and I think that there's a lot
more to food than nutrition the reason I
was eaten that way had nothing to do
with me thinking that it was the best
diet the reason I was eating that way is
because I just wanted to live as close
to that environment as possible and
that's what was available right so I
know some people are thinking well this
is a really healthy diet maybe it is
maybe isn't but that wasn't my
motivation what I yield how would I when
you had a good amount of it what I felt
was that if I ate too much meat it had
bad effects what kind of bad I believe I
believe my body started to feel weird I
believe that you can only handle so much
protein but you can handle a lot of fat
what I found is I had to eat most of my
calories from fat I would eat a half a
pound of solid pure fat a day when I was
eating just meat and fat I might eat two
or three even four pounds of meat a day
but but like a half a pound of it was
pure fat and weight but it was a form of
it was a bear fat or were you getting
your fat from it would be moose fat it
would be sheep fat something one year it
was bear fat or fat is weird right
because it's a different caribou fun
chewy fat like a deer fat so it's not
really but you know I'm saying it's like
it's not like like it doesn't render
down like beef fat wood moose fat yeah
oh sure does render you can render it if
you want i rendered along it's a
different like the way you look at it on
the animal it just seems different
what's different about it is that those
game animals do not put on fat within
the muscle right it's separate right if
you get a fat moose he'll have a big fat
layer on his back and so you would
render that fat or
that's how you do I mean I'll eat it all
the way when I'm butchering the moose in
the field I start eating the fat right
there
really sure Wow grab it off the kidneys
and stuff and start eating it so that
was the key for you was to get enough
fat I had to eat a lot of fat and then I
would feel better if you're just eating
protein for me it didn't work like what
what how did it make you feel it made me
feel like I had drink an awful lot of
water whenever I like you had to drink
an awful lot yeah I drink a lot of water
or I feel kind of like just a weird
feeling inside I mean that I also you
know is working really hard physically
at those times but I definitely drinking
more than a gallon of water a day
sometimes almost two gallons of water a
day when I'd be like in real cold
weather climbing mountains and
everything eating meat and fat all the
time
mmm yeah I'd be drinking a lot of water
and the other thing that's really
important to me like when I hear people
talking about how they eat a high meat
diet or ketogenic diet now and they're
just eating beef mm-hmm I wonder you
know what they're doing for a variety
because for me I was eating all
different parts of the animal all the
different organs and things and also a
lot of it I'd eat raw or half dried for
example was one of my favorite ways to
eat caribou meat when I was eating you
know this meat fat diet now I eat more
vegetables and fruits and and I still
like to eat a lot of meat but I do eat
more vegetables and fruits you feel
better that way personally yeah I like
more I like variety
I like a mix I mean I felt good when I
was eating that stuff but like I say I
would eat I would not feel good if I was
just eating steaks every day right if I
was just eating steaks every day I would
I would feel strange but if I took a
caribou backstrap and I just sliced it
up thin and hung it over the wood stove
and left it there for half a day or
something would get a little you know
dry on the outside but it'd still be raw
inside that stuff was delicious I'd be
like candy for me I just pig out I love
that and what we do with the crust eat
it oh you mean you mean the crust on big
pieces that have been hanging around all
winter yeah that gets turned into bait
that gets fed to the animals okay if
it's do you ever try to eat that the
only crust that
because that's where the oxidized blood
is basically it turns really dark
they'll get almost black sometimes
they'll be for some reason like down
around the shank on a big animal like a
moose when you're cutting it up into
smaller pieces the crust looks so clean
and everything down there you can eat it
like dry meat but most of the crust on
most of the big sections of meat get
black and they get I would not consider
that food it gets like it's it's not the
same as dry meat that you take a fresh
piece of meat and dry it for a few days
this is coming from a guy who ate the
contents of animal stomachs so I trust
you sometime when you say it's not meat
it's not food don't eat it not that not
that black crust that it's just blood
it's oxidized blood yeah
what's good but you want your blood real
fresh right yeah like that's the thing
with blood is like a lot of times I
haven't even been able to eat the blood
from an animal because I'm just too busy
but that's the thing is that you can eat
the stomach you can eat the intestine
you can eat the coal and I've eaten the
colon of a moose you can eat the lungs
even you can eat spleen I've eaten all
the stuff but the truth is if you're one
guy working alone butchering a moose you
have a hard time getting all that stuff
preserved and prepared you know yeah cuz
it like if you want to eat the colon you
want to get the [ __ ] out of it fast
before it gets hard like a big boy what
is the calling of a moves taste like oh
a donkey no it's great cuz well when you
do it right all it is is fat it's just
it's like Donuts it's like fat don't you
slice it what you do if you want to eat
the clone of mooses old guy that was
married to an Eskimo told me this and it
works you uh you got to work fast when
you when you take the colon out of your
next I'll try this out Joe okay turn it
inside out the poop off a sock turn it
inside out like a sock okay you got the
outside you got the inside out it's all
smooth right you know how the outside of
the colon to the large intestine is full
of fat like on any animal you know
there's all this fat all over it that's
gonna be on the inside now you just wash
that you know take it home and wash it
good get it get the lining all nice and
clean
then you slice it like doughnuts and fry
it up and what it tastes like
delicious does anything that resembles
that would resonate with people at it's
like good nice fat Wow I mean there's
all kinds of fat I have a hard time
describing exact taste what does it
taste the people always ask me that well
you might think I'm mousse : yeah I'm
saying there might be four other people
that know what that tastes like
oh no no you up go up in some village in
northern Alaska
Tarla vivo old people you know you find
old people eat stuff like they've grown
up 70 80 year-old Native people
[Applause]